les sabres au micro bonjour je les
filles sans rire pour une fois de vous
présenter le débat du siècle qui a lieu
ce soir et qui verra s'affronter
monsieur georges bach premier ministre à
monsieur raymond marché secrétaire
général du parti communiste et je crois
qu'on fait de grands signes en exil n'a
pas du tout c'est vraiment ma vie
effectivement les faits mais à l'envers
s'cusez moi c'est monsieur raymond barre
premier ministre à monsieur georges
marchais secrétaire général du parti
communiste
le tirage au sort ayant désigné monsieur
raymond barre c'est à vous monsieur
raymond barre d'ouvrir ce débat sur pea
pain je vous fais un grand vide